Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Sunucu: Yılın Girişimcisini açıklıyorum:
Ozan Ulusoy.
(Alkış)
Ali: Ozan, ödülü aldığın zaman
yaptığın konuşmada ne söylemiştin?
Ozan: Ben bu ödülü aldığımda,
O: Tüm Down Sendromlu aileler
adına aldım, demiştim.
A: Tüm Down Sendromlu aileler
adına aldım, demiştin.
O: Evet.
A: Bana engelli bir çocuk büyütmenin
nasıl bir duygu olduğu hep sorulur.
İşte anlatıyorum.
Bir çocuk beklemek,
İtalya'ya seyahat planına benzer.
Venedik'te gondollar,
Michelangelo'nun Davut'u,
Kolezyum;
her şey, her şey çok etkileyicidir.
İtalyanca birkaç kitap alırsınız,
broşürler alırsınız
ve İtalyanca öğrenmeye başlarsınız.
Derken, doğum vakti gelir.
Doğum, iki saatlik bir
uçak yolculuğuna benzetilebilir.
Uçağa binersiniz,
inişte hostes eline mikrofonu alır ve
"Sayın yolcularımız,
Hollanda'ya hoş geldiniz." der.
"Hollanda mı?
Ne Hollandası? Ben İtalya'ya gidiyorum!
İtalya'ya bilet aldım ben!" dersiniz.
"Hayır, uçuş rotası değiştirildii
ve artık siz Hollanda'da kalacaksınız."
Sizi pis, iğrenç,
kötü bir yere bırakmamışlardır.
Bıraktıkları yer beklediğinizden
farklı bir yerdir, o kadar.
Oradaki yaşam, İtalya'daki kadar
hızlı ve hareketli değildir.
Mecburen Hollanda'da kalırsınız
ve Hollandaca öğrenmeye başlarsınız.
Ve birden, Hollanda'nın
yel değirmenlerini fark edersiniz.
Hollanda'nın laleleri vardır.
Hatta Hollanda'nın
Rembrandt'ı bile vardır.
Fakat çevrenizdeki herkes
İtalya'ya gidip gelmekte
ve size İtalya'nın ne kadar etkileyici
olduğunu anlatıp durmaktadırlar.
İçinizden siz de,
"Ben de İtalya'ya gitmenin
düşünü kurmuştum." dersiniz.
Yitirdiğiniz düş önemli bir düştür,
ancak tüm yaşamınızı İtalya'ya
gidemediğiniz için üzülerek geçirirseniz,
Hollanda'nın güzelliklerinin
hiçbirinin farkına varamazsınız,
diyor bir öykü Tavuk Suyuna Çorbalar'dan.
Ozan, kendini bir tanıtır mısın?
O: Tabii.
Ben 1988 Kahramanmaraş
Elbistan doğumluyum.
A: Peki, adının Ozan olmasından
hoşnut musun?
O: Evet.
A: Bazılarımız dünyaya şiir olmaya,
bazılarımız şiir yazmaya,
bazılarımız da şiir okumaya gelmiştir.
Siz hangisi için geldiniz?
Ozan hem şiir okumaya,
hem de şiir yazmaya geldi.
Karşınızda, Aşkın Şarkısı adlı
şiir kitabı da olan,
ikinci baskısını yapmış bir şair var.
(Alkış)
Ozan belki de bize şimdi bir şiir okursun.
O: Tabii.
"Ağlasam sesimi duyar mısınız,
Mısralarımda;
Dokunabilir misiniz,
Gözyaşlarıma, ellerinizle?
Bilmezdim şarkıların bu kadar güzel,
Kelimelerinse kifâyetsiz olduğunu
Ben bu derde düşmeden önce.
Bir yer var, biliyorum;
Her şeyi söylemek mümkün;
Epeyce yaklaşmışım, duyuyorum;
Anlatamıyorum."
Orhan Veli Kanık
(Alkış)
A: Evet, Ozan 1988 yılında
Kahramanmaraş'ın Elbistan ilçesinde
Jeoloji mühendisi olarak çalışırken,
ki sonrasında Hukuk'u bitirdim,
orada doğdu.
İki çocuğumuz var, annesi de burada.
Birisinin adı Ozan olsun istedik;
şiir olsun, şiir okusun diye.
Bol bol şiir okuyacağız hep birlikte.
Bir de ikinci çocuğumuzun adı da Barış.
Dünyada ve yurtta barış olsun diye.
Ozan, kardeşinle aran nasıl?
O: Pek iyi olduğu söylenemez.
A: Neden?
Her çocuk gibi,
belki bütün kardeşler öyledir.
Ne olsa daha mutlu olurdun?
Öyle sorayım istersen sana.
O: En azından bir abisi olduğum için
biraz ilgilenmesini isterdim.
A: Abisi oldu. Hmm, güzel.
Peki,
Ozan aramız kalacaksa,
kimseye söylemeyecekseniz
özel konulara da girebiliriz bugün.
Aşk konusunu konuşmamızda
bir sıkıntı var mı?
O: Yok.
A: Ozan, okul öncesi
eğitim kurumlarına devam etti
ve Sincan Belediyesi'nin
Vedat Dolakay Kreşinde eğitime devam etti.
Daha sonra,
Eryaman'daki Öykü Kreş
ve Gündüz Bakımı'na devam etti.
Ozan müzeleri gezmeyi çok sever,
müzeler çünkü bir öğrenme yeridir.
Doğru mu?
O: Doğrudur.
A: Peki, Etnografya Müzesi'ndeki
o anını anlat istersen.
O: Tabii.
(Gülüşmeler)
A: Şimdi benim o zamanlar
Merve diye bir sevdiğim vardı.
A: Yaş kaç?
O: Yaşımı hatırlamıyorum.
A: Beş ya da altı.
O: İşte Etnografya Müzesi'ne gittik.
O dönemleri belki unutmuş olabilirsiniz.
İşte ne bileyim, öğretmenler
kız-erkek diye sıralar oluşturuyordu--
A: O zamanlar kızlı erkekli
sıralara girilebiliyordu rahatça.
O: Öğretmen her seferinde
hani gruptan taşan varsa
diye kontrol etmeye çalışıyordu bizi.
Bir öne gidip bir arkaya geliyordu.
Pardon, bir öne bir ortaya geliyordu.
Ben de sevdiğim Merve ile ortadaydım.
A: Evet.
O: Daha sonra,
ben bir, tabii o sefer ben bir...
madem öğretmen öne gidip ortaya geliyor,
öğretmeni öne git diye, tam da
bu sefer biz de arkaya geçtik.
A: Ne yaptın arkada?
O: Kızla yan yana geçip
el ele tutuştuk.
A: O kadar canım, masumca bir şey.
Evet, Ozan ilkokula devam etti.
Öncelikle tüm öğretmen arkadaşlarımıza
da çok teşekkür ediyoruz.
Gerçekten eğer Sevil Öğretmen
olmasaydı o ilkokulda,
Ozan eğitime devam edemeyecekti.
Ozan, başarılı bir öğrenciydi.
Seviye tespit sınavında,
Eryaman Etimesgut ilçesinde yapılan
bir seviye tespit sınavında,
beşinci sınıftayken 2100
çocuk arasında 1875. olmuştu.
Ne kadar büyük bir mutluluk
biliyor musunuz!
(Alkış)
Okuldaki 50 kişi arasında 40. olması
ne kadar büyük bir mutluluk
bizim için biliyor musunuz!
O: 32'ydi.
A: 32'ydi.
O: Evet, evet.
Peki Ozan,
her şey böyle mükemmel mi gitti
senin hayatında?
O: Tabii ki her insanın olduğu gibi,
benim de her şeyim mükemmel değildi.
A: Evet evet Ozan beşinci sınıfı bitirdi,
beşinci sınıfı bitirdi, Ankara'da
iki tane alışveriş merkezi vardı:
birisi Eskişehir yolunda,
birisi İstanbul yolunda.
Biz gittik ceketlerini aldık,
takım elbiselerini aldık.
Ağustos ayı, Eylül ayı okullar açılacak.
Okula kayıt yaptırmaya gittiği zaman
annesiyle Ozan,
oradaki müdür yardımcısı demiş ki,
"Hoca Hanım, siz Ozan'ı buraya mı
kaydettireceksiniz?"
Eşim bir şey söyleyememiş,
beni telefonla aradı.
2-3 gün sonra ben gittim Ozan'la birlikte.
Okulun bahçesinde müdüre hanımı
görünce Ozan gitti ona bir sarıldı.
"Ozancığım sen burada durur musun?" dedim
ve biz müdüre hanımla yukarı çıktık.
O: Sonra o sırada tüm Türkiye'nin yaptığı
gibi, ben de kantinde atıştırıyordum
(Kahkaha)
A: Evet, müdüre hanımın yanına çıktım,
dedim ki,
"Müdürüm, ben bir öğretmen çocuğuyum.
Köy Enstitüsü mezunu
bir babanın çocuğuyum.
Size bir öykü anlatmak istiyorum.
Yaban arılarının aerodinamik
yasalarına göre uçamaması gerekirmiş;
kanatlarının şekli, vücut ağırlığı
ve orantısızlığı nedeniyle.
Ama yaban arıları uçuyorlarmış.
Çevresindeki hiç kimse ona,
'Sen yaban arısısın uçamazsın,'
demediği için
ya da dedilerse de
o duymadığı için uçuyormuş.
Benim yaban arısı bir oğlum var.
Okulunuza devam etti ve başarılı.
2100 çocuk arasında 1875. oldu.
Ben ona nasıl derim
'Sen bu okula gitmeyeceksin
artık 6. sınıfa', derim.
Okula devam eder,
kalırsa, bir gerekçemiz olur
ona söylerim." dedim.
"Ali Bey olur mu öyle şey!
Biz Ozan'ı çok seviyoruz." dedi
ve Ozan okula devam etti.
Sevgili TED kolejliler
ve sevgili değerli arkadaşlarımız
biz engelli çocuk anne ve babaları
haddimizi ve sınırımızı çok iyi biliriz,
arka sıralarda oturmak
bize daha iyi gelir.
Okuma, sınıflardaki
yazılılar okunuyor, geliyorlar.
"Güliz 5, aferin.
Ayşe 5, aferin.
Mehmet 5, aferin.
Merve 4, aferin.
Ozan 1, ama Ozan çok başarılı."
Evet, gerçekten Ozan çok başarılıydı
çünkü Ozan, olması gereken kadar,
kendi kapasitesi kadar başarılıydı
ve sadece başarı da hiçbir zaman
matematik falan değildi.
Evet 5. sınıf bitti, 8. sınıf.
Ozan sen engelli olduğunu
ne zaman anladın?
Farklı olduğunu ne zaman anladın?
O: Az önce senin dediğin gibi,
ilkokul 5. sınıfta.
A: Evet, Ozan 5. sınıfta yazmış olduğu
bir mektupla arkadaşlarına,
"Arkadaşlarım aramızdaki farkı
biliyorsanız, lütfen utanmayın söyleyin.
Arkadaşlarım sizden rica ediyorum,
aramızdaki farkı çalışır düzeltirim."
diye bir mektubu vardı.
Evet, Ozan 5. sınıfı bitirdi,
8. sınıfı da bitirdi.
Rehber öğretmenine sorduk,
rehber öğretmen dedi ki,
"Ozan bir liseye gidemez.
Gitmemesinde yarar umuyoruz.
Ona bir meslek edindirseniz,
daha iyi olur." dedi.
Biz de meslek lisesi de olmaz dedik
ve çıraklık mesleki eğitimle ilgili
önce engellilerin
gittiği bir okula gittik.
İki okula gittik, oradaki müdürler
"Yok olmaz" dediler,
çünkü Ozan gerçekten başarılı.
Ozan'a burada yazık olur.
Bir çıraklık mesleki eğitim
bölümüne gittik.
Çıraklık mesleki eğitimde
dört gün çalışacaktı bir işte,
bir gün de okula gidecekti.
Ben de çok samimi,
çok sevdiğim bir arkadaşım
turizm işiyle uğraştığı için,
Ozanlar da sempatik, güler yüzlü olduğu
için hizmet sektöründe çalışır diye
arkadaşımın yanında işe koydum.
Üçüncü gün arkadaşım aradı,
"Ali" dedi, "Ozan uyuyor."
Tüm Türkiye uyuyordu,
ama Ozan'ın uyuduğu göze battı.
"Tamam arkadaşım," dedim
ve ben Ozan'ı kendi iş yerime aldım,
çünkü Opal Yayıncılık Organizasyon
ve Ticaret Limited Şirketi
diye bir şirketim vardı.
Orada yayıncılık bölümünde,
Ozan'ın bölümünü değiştirdik
ve hangi bölümde eğitim aldın?
O: Çengel Kafe...
A: Yok, okuldaki çıraklık eğitimde matbaa.
Matbaa genel bölümününde okudu,
daha sonra ne oldu?
Kalfa oldu.
Kalfa oldu ve Ozan gerçekten iş yerinde
benim yönetici asistanlığımı
yaptı arkadaşlar.
Çünkü telefonlara bakıyordu.
Şöyle düşündüm,
%70-80 onun dedikleri anlaşılır,
ee normal insanın da %70-80'i anlaşılıyor.
Çok da iyi not alıyordu.
Bana not alıyordu,
yönetici sekreterin yapması gereken.
Ama hatırlıyor mu bakalım,
o dönemde neler yapıyordun
şirketimizde çalışırken?
O: Tabii ben biraz işten kaytarıyordum.
A: Olur o kadar canım.
O: İşte 9-10 gibi işe gidip 11'de
öğlen yemeği, saat 2'de de eve gidiyorum.
(Kahkaha)
A: Evet, Ozan okulu bitirdi,
çırak oldu ve Çankaya Belediyesi'nin
Çengel Kafe'sinde
garson olarak çalışmaya başladı
ve 10 yıl mı, 7 yıl orada çalıştın.
Neler yaptın garsonluk dışında,
hangi tiyatrolarda oynadın
bize söyler misin?
O: Tabii.
William Shakespeare'in
Antonius ve Kleopatra oyununu oynadık.
A: William Shakespeare'in
Antonius ve Kleopatra'da oynadın.
O: Hamlet'i oynadık.
A: Hamlet'de oynadı.
O: Mikroplar Köyümüzde'yi oynadık.
A: Mikroplar Köyümüzde.
O: İlk oyunumuz Köyde Düğün'dü.
A: Köyde Düğün'dü.
O: Buzlar Çözülmeden'i oynadık.
A: Buzlar Çözülmeden'i oynadı.
O: Şinasi'nin Şair Evlenmesi oyununda.
A: Şinasi'nin Şair Evlenmesi'nde
sanat için...
O: Soyundum ve kadın kılığına girdim.
A: Sanat için soyundu
ve kadın kılığına girdi.
(Alkış)
Evet, Ozan daha sonra
bir teknoloji mağazasında
Down Sendromu Derneği'nin bir teknoloji
mağazasıyla yaptığı anlaşmayla,
orada çalıştı, asgari ücretle çalıştı.
10 ay boyunca çalıştı ve daha sonra...
O: "Ben sanatçı adamım ne işim var burada"
diyerek istifaya başvurdum.
A: "Ben sanatçı adamım,
niye oyuncak satıyorum" diye istifa etti
ve İŞKUR için,
iyi ki matbaa bölümü de okumuş,
ben bir proje yazdım.
Engelli İlk Down Sendromlu Girişimci
olarak İŞKUR tarafından desteklendi
ve İlk Down Sendromlu Girişimci oldu.
Down Reklam Ajansını kurdu.
Daha sonra da ODTÜ tarafından
yılın girişimcisi ödülünü aldı.
Ne hissettin?
O: Tabii, öncelikle ben böyle
büyük bir okuldan da ödül almak
beni biraz gururlandırdı.
A: Evet, fırsat verilirse
önce aileyi eğitirsek,
fırsat verilirse herkes başarılı olur.
Başarı her zaman meşhur olmak değildir,
başarı her zaman
çok paralı olmak da değildir.
Başarı her zaman kendin olmaktır,
insan olmaktır.
(Alkış)
On iki yıl önce Adana'ya tekrar gelmiştim,
Adana Cezaevi'nde 16 yaşında
Gökhan diye bir çocuk vardı.
Benim çocuğumun yaşındaydı
ve benim çocuğum kadar güzel
ve benim çocuğum kadar yakışıklıydı
ve ben o zaman o soruyu sormuştum:
Gökhan'ın orada olmasından
sadece anne babası değil,
ben de sorumluyum.
Hepimiz her şeyden sorumluyuz.
O zaman Nazım Hikmet'ten
bir şiirle bitirelim mi birlikte?
O: Daha önce ben bir şey söylemek
istiyorum.
B: Hay hay.
O: Tek bu başarımın dışında,
başka başarılar da elde ettim ben.
A: Ne?
O: Ben TRT1'de Seksenler dizisinde
bir iki bölüm,
bölüm oyuncusu olarak oynadım.
A: Seksenler dizisinde oynadın.
Evet, Ozan'ın başarıları çok.
2008 yılında kanser tedavisi gördü
ve bir savaşçı oldu.
Ozan'ın başarısı büyük,
Ozan çoklu organ yetmezliği var
ama mücadelesine devam ediyor,
çünkü Ozan kendisinden daha sonra
gelecek olan Down Sendromlulara karşı
bir sorumluluk taşıyor.
"Güzel günler göreceğiz çocuklar
(Alkış)
Güneşli güzel günler,
Motorları maviliklere süreceğiz çocuklar
Işıklı maviliklere süreceğiz
Açtık mıydı hele bir son vitesi,
adedi devir.
Motorun sesi.
Uuuuuuuy! çocuklar kim bilir
ne harikûlâdedir
160 kilometreyle giderken öpüşmesi...
Hani şimdi bize çiçekli bahçeler vardır,
yalnız cumaları
yalnız pazarları..
Hani şimdi biz
bir masal hayvanı gibi seyrederiz
77 katlı mağazaları.
Hani bunlar yekpare camdan mağazalardır.
Hani şimdi bizim evimize
haftada bir et gelir.
Ve
çocuklarımız işten eve iskelet gelir..
Hani şimdi biz..
İnanın:
güzel günler göreceğiz çocuklar
güneşli güzel günler
Motorları maviliklere süreceğiz çocuklar,
ışıklı maviliklere
süre-
-ceğiz.....
Topraktan ateşten ve denizden
doğanların
en mükemmeli doğacak bizden...
..................... ve insanlar ellerini
korkmadan
düşünmeden
birbirlerinin ellerine bırakarak
ve yıldızlara bakarak:
- 'Yaşamak ne güzel şey!'
diyecekler;
ve bir insan gözü gibi derin
ve bir salkım üzüm gibi serin
bir ferah
bir rahat
bir işitilmemiş şarkı söyliyecekler...
Hiçbir ağaç
böylesine harikulâde bir yemiş vermemiş
olacaktır
Ve en vadedici
bir yaz gecesi bile
böyle sesler
böyle inanılmaz renklerle
sabaha ermemiş olacaktır.
Topraktan
ateşten
ve denizden
doğanların
en mükemmeli doğacak bizden.............."
(Alkış)